that's why we were boyfriend yesh guess
you gotta get going to honking behind
you he's got a big show you're taking up
time and you're an unknown she's an
unknown and she has a boyfriend we can
waste time with guests like that what if
this was sweeps let's go into hell why
you I should fire you what kind of jokes
you given me competition's fierce man I
did what you said I made these cool gift
bags for our guests now they'll tell all
their friends what
hi bob saget just want to get on the lot
please ladies and gentlemen Bob second
since I'm hosting a show on you hosted
shows any advice for me I just want to
get on a lot this is not there's no
there's no show here this year at your
security guard hello cameras rolling
actually I like it's funny too there's
no show here this is a security booth
okay I Bob will have to finish that
great story some other time get miss get
back to word will get out and tell us on
to celebrity friends about our show this
is obviously been used many times before
by other people this is it's just swag
back for being on our show you
could you please so that this is this
crap I don't know none of this cool
stuff look deeper I just I just cut
myself on this well there's neosporin
for that huh see all your friends
there's no lid on it I mean seriously
you have a job but but get one open the
gate okay please bye
there went well remember I'm Fred and I
man the gate the great entertainment
tune in tomorrow you idiot Bob second
and a great story no he's not gonna want
to be on a show again of all the
eastgate gonna get all the great games
yeah because you're messing up maybe you
should transfer to the east gate that
would work now tell me this is my home
I'm not moving my coat and hat to put
your foot